we actually just think we should just be
good at relationships we don't even get
a lesson on it i got zero lessons on it
and i went to catholic school so i
actually started with negative lessons
you know and i was taught that there was
a giant white guy in the cloud with a
beard that would decide if i was a good
guy or a bad guy like it's so stupid and
you don't get to find out till you get
to the gates like how dumb is that so
much of you even of our perception of
self externalized that that god is
outside of you but anyone's who's
experienced love i think it's alan watts
who says
ask anyone who doesn't believe in god
ask them that when they're having an
orgasm
when we stop running from our challenges
relationally that's where the gold is as
you said i mean i i think the challenge
culturally is that we are taught to
avoid conflict we're not taught the
skills to build bridges we're not taught
the skills to deepen relationship we're
taught that if someone has an opposing
view or an opposing way of being that
they're just wrong